starting this hour off Giovanni is with
us in Phoenix hi Giovanni how are you
well the only way I could be better with
a brand new free pair of size-10 shoes
Dave what's up in your world man well
the church that I go to
not a very big Church only a few of us
are probably six-figure households a lot
of the money that the church gets in
goes out to missionary and they're very
open you know to where all the money is
we can see where all the money is going
to I've taken it upon myself to you know
my tithing my wife and I you know are we
giving cash but part of it you know I'm
a technology guy and I'm an awesome
musician I like quality instruments and
those are not you know cheap so between
you know what the church needs are and
what I like to do I tend to split my
tithe you know I just want to see what
your take is on that okay
well the the point is not whether you're
meeting some obligation with God the
question is what is he teaching us
through this can you check a box is what
you're asking and I would back up and
say that's probably just the wrong
question the part the purpose of the
tithe a tenth of our income going to our
local church that's what the tithe is
it's it says it's a tenth of your net
increase is to teach us the rhythm of
giving as our income has rhythm our
giving has rhythm and those of us that
are evangelicals that attend a church or
attend the church that is Orthodox in
some methodology some kind of a some
kind of a doctrinal way that believe in
the tithe then you know what we're
taught and what has been taught for
fifteen hundred years is to give a tithe
of your net increase as says in
Deuteronomy and so your profits your
taxable income in other words but again
that's not a thing that says okay God
likes tithers better than
on either x' or he's waiting to bless
you until you do this he loves all his
kids he is instead saying my son the
best way to live your life the best way
to have a great life is to be a giver
the baseline the starting point for
giving is a tenth of your income going
into your local church
I completely divorce myself emotionally
from managing that money for the church
meaning I just it's not mine it's God's
I lay it at the feet of the church
whatever the church does with it they're
going to do with it now if I think the
church is being irresponsible
financially I will do one of two things
I would get involved with the leadership
team and just challenge the
responsibility not based on my tithing
but just based on the fact that they're
being irresponsible and if I think
they're being irresponsible continually
I'll leave because a financial
irresponsibility means they're probably
irresponsible with other things that are
spiritual and that scares me so none of
that's coming up in this discussion but
just kind of some overall statements to
think about so what would I do if I were
in your shoes I would separate the
purchase of instruments or the donation
of your time for technology or the
purchase of technology into the offering
category and it would be separate than
your tithe category that's a technical
Bible study that I'm doing here with you
again
I don't think God's gonna be mad at you
if you do it the way you're doing it and
the way not the way I'm doing it that is
not what I'm saying but there's just if
you read through Scripture and begin to
understand the difference in a tithe and
an offering and offering is where you do
stuff with your time an offering is
where you do stuff like I've got some
you know a great guitar and this church
really is probably not going to purchase
a guitar that's nice and I'd love to be
able to play it while I'm there so I'm
gonna donate it to them you know I think
they need to get their act together on
their website so I'm gonna jump in and
help them when those are great things
that you're doing where you're donating
your skills your talents your times your
time and those kinds of things that
falls from a technical definition
standpoint in the offering bucket which
is separate and apart
from the tie the bucket in other words
you could do the same things you're
doing there with instruments or
technology or time with any ministry not
necessarily your local church the tithe
is not called to be given anywhere
except to your local church because it
follows the model of the Old Testament
storehouse now
some people disagree with all the stuff
I just said that's okay you can disagree
with it this is America you're the right
to be wrong it's okay I don't mind
it's okay do whatever you want to do
again I'm not I am NOT a legalist about
this stuff and I'm sure not a prosperity
guy a prosperity gospel guy but you just
enjoy the giving get I will tell you
this a hundred percent of people that I
find that have built wealth and enjoy
their lives and have a good quality life
are givers now I mean people who are
miserable built wealth but not many of
them most people we see that build
wealth are consistent givers there's a
there's a direct correlation in those
data points so it's good that Giovanni
that you're doing what you're doing
because that tells me you're heading in
the right direction on a whole lot of
different fronts but it grows your
spiritually when you do that rhythm of
the tithe and when you do the the the
one offs of the offering the giving of
the guitar or the giving of the laptop
you know or the giving of your time to
play either one of those things